great thank you welcome to introducing
more of the standard library
i'm simon ward jones i'm a senior data
scientist at deliveroo i work in the
experimentation and measurement team
where i work partly on experimentation
and a platform we've built in python to
calculate sort of
a b test statistics and powers for all
the experiments we run at delivery and
the other part of what i do is working
on our customer behavior model where we
try and project out all of our customer
behavior with causal inference and
statistics when you say that to give the
context in terms of what i do at work
i've been using python for about five
years
and
i thought i'd start with a fun fact
python is actually got nothing to do
with snakes and it comes from monty
python that is straight from the dock so
you can read it there
to talk a little bit about how python
code is organized if you were to start a
python interpreter or go into jupiter
this is very basic so i'm just covering
it quickly you'll be able to sort of
start using python as a calculator as
i'm sure lots of you have
or you could
you know create a list
and assign that to a variable and you
can think of these as sort of core data
types
you can also use the built-in functions
things like lists abs int there's a
whole collection of them and we call
these the built-ins and these all are
loaded immediately when you start using
python and you can use these straight
away but there's also things you have to
import so python code's always organized
into modules
and i can break the things you have to
import down into standard library
modules these are things that come with
python and that's what we're going to be
talking about today
and there's also
pipeline modules and third-party
packages that you're probably writing in
your companies
so i think it's good to before jumping
into talking about all the code we're
going to go through just very briefly
why learn the standard library this one
is again a quote from the docs the
python standard library is very
extensive offering a wide range of
facilities
uh so i mean it's already there let's
let's let's make use of it
also a point is don't reinvent the wheel
your wheel is likely not as good uh
here's my wonky wheel and so in terms of
code there's if there's a method that's
written in the standard library it's
probably going to be faster it's
probably going to be more memory
efficient than whatever you can kind of
come up with yourself
it's just about knowing that it's there
in the first place
uh on this point i think certainly
working in data science you get a lot of
graduates who are really intelligent and
can they've learned the list the for
loop and the eve and i'm certainly
guilty of this and you just go ahead and
attack every problem with just a really
small toolset when if you'd spend a
couple of hours learning about some of
the libraries we'll go through today you
could have probably done it a little bit
better coming on to the third point it
saves time it's less code
and the fourth point is it's
standardized for other developers so
they're likely to be more familiar with
the standard library than something you
could implement yourself so if you can
save them time sort of learning how
you've implemented it then then that's
going to be good also
python is considered to be batteries
included with more than 200 modules i've
put a selection of my favorite here
but what we're going to go over today is
pathlib date time collections ester
tools and func tools so i've kind of
given us quite a lot to get through but
hopefully you'll understand why these
modules are there what they can do for
you and
and some of the core api of those
modules so we've got pathlib for
representing file system paths
date time it's really in the name it's
for representing it gives you classes
for representing dates and time
collections gives you a selection of
container data types so the ones we're
really familiar with in python are lists
and dictionaries and tuples and sets but
collections gives you a few more on top
of that to use in specific
scenarios and we'll come to that
it's a tools helps you with iteration it
gives you the building blocks to iterate
in a smarter way or build new iterators
from existing iterators
if you're not familiar with iterators
we'll we'll get to that as well and
functools is tools for higher order
functions and and a higher order
function is just a function that takes
another function as an argument so it
kind of modifies an existing function
okay so that's it for the slides let's
uh
jump into the code in the abstract to
this talk i put a link so you could have
either already downloaded the repo or
download the repo now or you can just
open the code
in
colab directly from this link and if the
internet is good you can just
run the code directly from colab which
is
a google jupyter notebook version but
i'll
start it
i'm going to use
jupyter lab
uh yeah just a note notes before we jump
into the code and tell me that's too
small i might go
one more
uh
the modules i would say get more
advanced or at least they interact with
more advanced concepts of python as we
go so if you're completely new
hopefully you'll understand the
beginning half and then for the people
who are potentially more advanced in
python maybe they'll learn something a
bit more in the second half of the talk
we won't have time to go into every
single method in in every single of
these modules but we'll i'm trying to
give a flavor so you can go away and
then and then know where and what you
can use these tools for
there's also going to be an optional
exercise at the end of each section just
keep you on your toes and see if you've
understood
uh what i've gone through
so let's start by talking about pathlib
part lib is gives you a class called
path and we can import that by doing
from
heartlib import path
and a path is a specific location on
your on your computer so you can think
of it as a text file here or a
configuration file there or an excel
file and the path is just saying where
that is so you know the sort of forward
slash on
on your system
so here we can make a current working
directory by creating a path and giving
it a string with just a dot as our
argument to where the path is we can
have a look at that and it says it's a
posix path
and it is automatically detecting that
we're on a mac or a linux or just not
windows really and so it's giving us a
posix instead of a windows
and we can call the absolute method on
this instance and we can see exactly
where we are on my computer so this is
the path that this is representing
and we can also there's a shortcut
method on the path class just called
current working directory which is going
to give us exactly the same thing
so in terms of building paths how do you
how do you go ahead and build path
there's a few different methods you can
start off with a path instance here with
the current working directory and you
call the join path method to build up
a data folder from the current working
directory and in the subfolder student
data you can have a theme of student
data here
but that's that's my that's my path or
python has overloaded the forward slash
or the divide operator on this class so
you can just do a forward slash and then
the string so it's i quite like it other
people don't like it but i think it's
quite cool way of building a path
intuitively or starting from this
directory and then adding on subfolders
and we can do the same thing again by
just giving that a string so there's
three different ways of building our
path
and now let's
say we're gonna have a file in this
student folder called data.json
and so now we've got a path
we can have a look at that
and it's the data dot json with inside
that subfolder
so a quick bit about the attributes you
can use on these
paths we've got the dot name dot stem
and dot suffix representing the whole
name of the file
the stem and the suffix so the dot json
bit and we can call parts to get
all the different parts of the full path
to the folders and the
and the file name
when we print it we'll get back to a
nice string representation
calling.absolute's going to give you the
full
string from the root of the system
and this is quite nice you can have a
dot parent which is just going to say
what's the parent of that directory as a
property on that instance
and as it returns another path rather
than a string
it comes with all of the methods of a
path because it this is using the python
like an object representation of the of
the class so you can of the past sorry
so you can call dot parent get a get a
new path and then go to its parent as
well so you can use that recursively and
we can get back to the data folder
so
now we can talk about changing things
and manipulating it so we have our
student data path it's data.json we can
call the with suffix dot pi to change
that from a data.json to a data dot pi
and we can change the whole name using
with a with name method
and again i'm just going to say because
it's returning this object we can chain
methods which is quite nice so here we
we're saying with name numbers and then
we're saying with suffix
xls
yeah here's a point i just want to make
so far we've not actually
changed any files we've just created
representations of a specific place in
our system that doesn't necessarily mean
it's there we've just said this is
representing a path at this location so
now we can use some further methods that
are actually going to interact and check
with on our computer so we can say does
this file dot exist is going to go and
check and we don't actually have a
folder called data and we don't have a
subfolder and we don't have this file in
it
there's also two methods is file and it
is dir and they're going to check if
it's there and check whether it's a file
or whether it's a directory so if it's a
directory and it did exist is there
would return true it's file would return
false
hopefully that will make sense
so i'm going to call
i'm just going to see if this student
data folder exists this is the
data.student data so i took the the file
path we had
look found the folder by looking at its
parent and then i've checked and that
also doesn't exist
so we could go ahead and call this
makeder method
which is going to try and make the make
the path it's going to fail hopefully
and the reason is is because it's it's
trying to make a folder called student
data with insider subfolder data but
neither of these exist so it's
complaining that i can't make a folder
called student data in a
in a folder data that doesn't exist
uh so what what you can do is you can
say
parents equals true so that's going to
go ahead and make any parents missing
when you're trying to create this folder
and exists okay
if if the folder already exists then you
try and create it it will error and say
i already exist i'm just going to say
exists okay so if it was already there
we wouldn't get an error
so often you see people sort of checking
the file exists or having to make
parents and this makes it much easier
so now we can see that the folder exists
and so does oh but our data json doesn't
exist so let's go ahead and make that so
we've got some student data here
we've got john he's 10 and he's not on
vacation and there's scores we've got
jane doe
she's also 10 she's not on vacation
either and we've got isaac newton he's
30
and he's got some test scores there so
we can
write those into a list of dictionaries
and now we're going to import json
another standard library module i was
trying to avoid using other standard
library modules in the talk about
standard library modules but you can't
really get away with it so here you can
take this path and you can use the right
text method
and then i can just dump the json into a
nice format and that's going to go ahead
and write that json files we could
go in here
click on data student data and there's
the
data.json file let me just close that
and there's also a method
which is called read text
which is just going to read the text
from this file location and i'm just
going to print that there so you can see
i've made that file
it's just a bit big
so now renaming a file another common
thing you're going to want to do
is we're going to first create the
location where we want it to go so here
i'm saying my student data path and
go up to the parent folder and then the
parent of that one so i'm going
basically one step up and i'm changing
the name to new location.text i've not
done anything yet i've just made this
theoretical location which is data for
slash new location
and then this is the line that's
actually going to move it so you're
taking this file path and renaming it to
this file path and it's going to it's
going to move that so i'm just checking
if
the
location where i want to put it doesn't
exist
let's go ahead and
write that over so now you can see this
new location exists and if we were to go
into
the student data folder that's not in
there now because we've moved it up into
the data folder
does anyone if you also if you have any
questions at any point just sort of
um yeah it's also the os module yes
yeah great question uh in the os pretty
much every method you've got in pathlib
you're going to have in os in fact
there's many more in os but for for just
paths
path lib provides this object-oriented
way of viewing a path so you can use
these kind of nice forward slashes and
it's not you can't you don't think of it
as a string it's going to return another
path
rather than a string
but it does make working with it easy
because of some of the kind of bits
above where you can get the stem the
parents you can call move methods easier
and then deleting files to delete a file
you would use the unlink method
and to remove a empty folder you'd call
remove directory
so i can delete the files
and obviously this one would have
existed and the
student original location then no longer
would have existed but i'm just checking
if they exist and then deleting them and
same with the directories
you have to have
a empty directory to
delete the directory
i'm just going to make those again
because i actually want them
another really useful method is the
itada it's going to return all of the
files or folders with inside this folder
so i can show you that as a list but
they're all the different things with
inside this this folder
and a nice method is glob which matches
a pattern
and provides you an iterator through the
pattern so here i just want to find in
any sub directory so the double stars
means check any subfolder any file name
as long as it ends.jpeg bring me that
yeah and a fairly bad example because i
don't have any jpegs in this example but
we could do json and hopefully we'll
find uh the data.json and there's also
this random one from uh jupiter
so that that is a whistle stop tour of
uh path lib and as a first exercise i'm
going to give you one minute to try and
write a function called replace all text
with markdown so i want you to find all
the folders
in the current working directory
and
replace txt with a dot md so you want to
change them from text to markdown
so see if you can write a
write a function to do that i'll give
you about a minute
for those for those having a go
so
bye
i'll give you one one more minute see
how you're getting on then i'll show you
an
answer i'm sure there's many ways we
could do this
okay i think what i'll do is i'll show
you an answer now and uh
hopefully you're almost there so here
i've got replace all text with i've i've
just scrambled it so you couldn't see it
immediately but if we go up and paste
this into
our example
here i'm saying for file path
in
path dot current working directory so
that's going to bring get us a path uh
instance for the current working
directory and then we're going to call
the dot glob method
matching any uh any file as long as it
ends.txt and then we're going to rename
that
to the file path with suffix dot
markdown so that's like a nice example
of
and we can test that we can write a file
uh so we can say path of example.txt
we can write some text into it
and it returns nine which is the number
of bytes you've written i think
and we can call my method i've just
written
and
now
i could actually before i unlink it
we can read text
which is the method we're going to call
to check it's there so you can see this
example.markdown file now exists because
we moved the example.txt we can
and i can go ahead and
unlink that to delete it
so that was that was part lib it's a
really really handy library and it's
quite i think it's nicer to use than the
os uh path
type methods
so we're doing okay for time as i said
it's going to get gradually more more
more advanced topics so date time
is a module for supplying classes for
manipulating dates and time
just a really quick note on time zones
date time objects are categorized as
either aware or naive depending on
whether they include a time zone
in general i tend to just not use time
zones but
if you are then i'd recommend looking at
sort of other libraries as well like
high tzed
are going to make it or pendulum that
make it a bit easier but the the key
classes are date
time and date time
so date represents a date time or time
a date time a combination of the two and
a time delta is a duration between
between two dates
some some more notes objects are
immutable and by that it means that you
can't change them once you've made them
and that's useful because you can use
them as keys and dictionaries
uh objective these types are hashable
sorry which means you can use some
mistakes new keys
and
they support efficient pickling via
pickle module that's straight from the
docs so let's make a date we're going to
call datetime.date with three arguments
year month and day this is the 24th
of april yeah
i've named it 24th of april good name
uh we can also use the today method
which is going to return a date for
today the 17th
of june
and we can get the attributes day month
and year on on that date time
instance and i'm just building them into
a tuple time we can build 430 by doing
16 30 and zero seconds zero milliseconds
so now we have 4 30 that's the time
and we can build a date time here is the
16th of september 8 30
and 12 seconds
so we can fill out all of those and
again i'm saying no time zone info so
that's a specific order potentially at
delivery
you can get from the date time back to
the date and the time with the date and
time methods respectively the
and similar to the today method on date
there's a useful now method to get
right now as a date time
so what's that
158
you can call the combine method to get
from a date and a time back to the date
time
and we can print that as a string so
that's going to give a nice string
representation
by default
for the date time that's what the date
time would look like printed and that's
what a date would look like
iso format is a specific standard
formatting of strings and you can also
get today as they have a dot iso format
method which is very similar to the
print
and for the date time it's very similar
but it has a t between the date and the
time
but you can also go back so if you have
an iso format
string so here's the 24th we can say
date from iso format to get that get a
date from a string which is really handy
and we can do that from iso format for a
date time as well using the date time
dot from iso format
now i guess there's loads of different
formats use when you're working with
data for for dates and
there's a method called if you just look
down here we've got string from time and
it's going to take a specific
string format and uh
i'm just going to print that out to show
you what it looks what now would look
like
using these different formats
so percentage a or percentage capital a
and you can com you can combine these so
here percentage a will pick out the day
of the week in the three letter
abbreviation or percentage capital a is
a string of the of the
of the day and all of these different uh
kind of what are they called directives
are available
uh so here i've got a date that i might
have
uh in a this is this is a function for
going back the other way so if you have
a string representation of a date time
and you know it it's like uh it's
directive kind of format you can say
okay take me from a string back to the
date time as long as you've got it in
this regular format so here
this this a would be the the day then
you have a dash
and the date as a number you know and
you can use these to get back to the
daytime so these can be really handy
and this is kind of a full list they're
also in the python documentation
replace is a really handy method that's
on both uh the date object or a date
time
it's it's going to replace any of the
specific attributes that you that you
specify so here we can do 10a dot
replace
year is equal to today dot year minus
one so here we're getting the same day
but one year earlier
no pi data last year i don't think uh
so and similar with now
this daytime we could replace the hour
and make it this morning at six a.m
time delta
is the duration so this big time date
time data here you can specify in days
seconds microseconds
minutes hours weeks whatever you
whatever you want out of these and so
this is
50 days
eight hours and it's going to add those
all up and it's going to give us it back
by default in days seconds and
microseconds so you can see it's the sum
of all of those different sort of
durations this is i've now got a
time delta representing 64 days
and that many seconds
and you can go back to the total number
of seconds
uh by calling that on the delta if you
ever want if you wanted to
get get the second duration
so i'm just showing you that these two
things are exactly the same
here i've done a simple version of it as
365 days
and
this is also another year but in 40
weeks 84 days and i can just show you
that those two things are exactly the
same
it's just going to build it it just
represents one a duration
so that's a kind of pretty short
covering of date time i didn't go into
time zones but i thought it might be a
fun challenge to see if you can write a
function
that takes in two arguments a month
and a day and it's going to return the
number of days
until
uh your next birthday
so if you're
born on
september 16th we can call this
hopefully
like this so month 9 september
and day is 16.
so again i'll give you one i'll give you
one minute and then i'll
show you and i'll show you an answer
but we want a function that
gives us days until our birthday
probably too much
how are we getting angry you want one
more minute
okay i think everyone's still typing
okay i'll i'll i'll go through the
answer i've got here so i can unscramble
my hidden answer
and i'll just quickly explain how how i
use what we
what we went through above
so firstly i'm going to get today using
the dot today method on date
and i'm going to say birthday is equal
to today
and then i'm going to replace
the month
and day as given so basically i'm just
keeping the year
from today
but that could be in the past because it
could be
you know february the 2nd so i'm saying
if birthday is smaller than equal today
i'm going to go ahead and add
a year to
the the current year
and then i'm going to return birthday
minus
today and use the
dot days on that duration so we can uh
run that and we can see it's 244 days
until february 16th or
in my case what is it
91 okay not quite time to get excited
yet
[Music]
collections this is this is the next one
we're going through so we've gone
through pathlib and we've gone through
date time which are
great and we use them all the time for
instance i told you i was working on a
customer lifetime value model at
deliveroo
the first thing we do in that in that
python script at the beginning is we're
going to load our configuration file for
the model so we're going to read that
from a specific path lib folder
and then
in that we're going to read a date so we
want to find you know we want to predict
customers from yesterday who or who made
an order yesterday uh so that's an
example of the kind of thing that we're
using these all the time
so talking about collections this is a
module that implements a selection of
specialist container types so as i said
you're probably familiar with dictionary
so like for a mapping or list for
for a series of uh objects or numbers or
whatever you want a set
and a tuple so there tend to be covered
straightaway first thing
and these ones
that we're going to go through now we're
not going to go through them all
but we've got named tuple which is very
similar to a tuple
but each of the elements has a name so
for instance if you had a record
representing a specific thing you might
say oh the second thing in this record
represents someone's age
but you just have to know that if you're
using a tuple whereas a named tuple in
the code you can use sort of instead of
looking up that second item you can say
dot age which is much easier if you're
reading it
dec which is
i think how you pronounce it but it's a
double ended queue so it's similar to a
list it's just a series of things but
it's useful when you often want to put
items on the end of the list or put
items at the beginning of
the of the queue or take items off
either end so it's performant for both
ends of the for operating on both ends
of the of the queue
chain map
it allows you to combine multiple
mappings together so if you have two
dictionaries and you want to be able to
just look up
a value from either one
uh and you don't want to have to create
a whole new dictionary and sort of put
all the items from both into one
dictionary you can use a chain map and
it will just check the first mapping if
it's not there it's going to go ahead
and check the second mapping
a counter is really good for counting
and we're going to go i'll give you some
examples of that but if you've got an
iterable or a list of things and you
just want to go through and count all
the ones all the all the fours or just
count the items in that list that's what
counter is great for
and i'm not going to go i'm not going to
go through the
default date we will go through
but i think best showing through some
examples so we're going to import
counter deck default dict and named
tuple
and we're going to go through and show
you how to show you how they work
so here we're going to
use the counter class with a string
and ahead of time i think it's good when
you're looking at code you should try
and have a think what's it going to do
before before you run it and hopefully
you would you were thinking we're going
to get something like this which is a
mapping and counting each of the
individual letters within that string
in this instance we've got an iterable
of pets
or a list of pets and we can call
counter on that and it's going to go
through and count three dogs sorry
three cats two dogs and a goldfish
we can actually initialize it straight
away from
a dictionary if we wanted to
but it's clear to the person reading the
code why they're using a counter they
are they're counting something so it
also helps if you're reading someone
else's code you know we could have used
the dictionary here but it just gives
you a little bit more intuition that
they're definitely counting something
uh another useful thing is all missing
elements have uh zero so if we look if
we've got any sharks uh in the in our
pets counter we don't have any sharks
but it's gonna return zero rather than
throw an error
as a we would and we can go back to the
individual elements with the dot
elements method
and uh a really useful method is the
most common so now that we've counted
them you often want to find the most
common uh so here we can see that cat
and dogs out of a fairly small example
but you can imagine it being more useful
in the bigger one
uh what are the two most common pets
uh this is also nice and fast using
another standard library called heat cue
which i considered
going through but
it's a pretty algorithmic uh library and
i thought that would be
pretty full or not nothing for me uh
the
so here i can make another counter with
three cats and ten dogs
and it would do the intuitive thing in
all the kind of operation in all sense
so we add those two counters together
we'll get a counter with
six cats 12 dogs steal that one goldfish
i'm just showing you what we had in the
counter we have the original one we have
three cats two dogs and one goldfish so
this is how you might increment a
specific
key so we can say
counter get the dog and
add one value so now we have three dogs
so that's counter it's really useful for
counting next we'll go on to double
ended queue
so we can take range of five and make a
double ended queue and have a look at
that
and so we've got zero through four as
you'd expect from the range and we can
append
five
to the to the far end of the queue and
we can append left this is the kind of
method that we don't have
in a list you can insert but it's not as
performant if you so if you're doing
lots of adding on to both ends
specifically in something like like a
double ended queue type algorithm then
you then you'd use the double ended
queue so now if we have a look at it
you're going to have that extra five i
put on the right and the extra minus one
i put on the left
and we've got the similar methods extend
and extend left so we're gonna put six
seven eight
onto the right hand side of the list and
minus two minus three minus four
it's interesting to note that they're
the other way around so here it says
minus four minus three minus two
and you can think of it because it went
through adding the minus two first to
the left then it added the minus three
and then it added the minus four so
that's why they appear in the other
order
and we can use the index method to see
where's the three so it's in position
seven
uh we can call the dot reverse method
which is going to reverse our cue i've
said this is in place and you'll hear
that term a lot it just means that it
modifies
the the deck double ended queue in place
it doesn't create a new one so now if i
was to print that out you'll see it's in
reverse order
so that's pretty much
a double ended queue similar to a list
but
with queue functionality on both ends
you've also got this property called max
len and that this really does change it
because now we have a double ended queue
but with maximum length five so i'm just
gonna start it off with
naught to four
five numbers in it
now if i append five and look what we
have left
the zero fell off in the end when i
pushed five on to the end we've said
maximum length here is five so it's just
going to get rid of that zero and that's
gone and if i append left
put the zero back on the left then now
the five's fallen off so this can be
great for just keeping five track of
five things if you sort of don't mind
when they fall off the end and similar
if i extend five six seven
you'll see the zero the one and the two
have fallen off
if i extend left
again they're in reverse order two one
and zero but the
five six and seven are falling off
and you have a similar method uh or
conceptually it's quite easy to
understand what rotate two's going to do
it's just gonna rotate them all round so
we're not losing any here we're just
moving them all one to the right and
when they get to the end they just loop
back around and join the other end of
the queue
and you can get that attribute on on the
class to see what what's my max length
and let's just clear the queue so now
there's nothing in it
and just a note if you do have the
situation where you're initializing it
from five things
with a max length of three it's just
going to put them all in one by one and
then
so we'll put the one in then the two
then the three and then it will start
knocking them off
as you'd expect with maxline
uh default dict so here's a sentence
imagine we want to take a sentence and
store the word
in lists
in the dictionary keyed on the letter
that each word starts with that's the
sentence and i can print that
and i'm here i'm
imagining how i might do this if i don't
know about default dict
i want to have at the end of the day i
want to have each of the
uh i want a dictionary with letters and
then a list of all the words
that start with that letter that's what
that's the data structure i want to get
to so i'm saying for word in sentence
dot split
so this is going to give me each word
if the first letter is not already in my
dictionary
i'm going to
set
that letter to a new list with the word
in it so the first time i find a new
letter i need to create a new list
inside the dictionary otherwise i
already know it's a list so i can just
go ahead
and append the word to that list so
that's how you might implement this if
you want if you wanted to implement it
and you didn't know about default dict
in default dict you specify
what should what uh
what to call or what to create when
you first when you look up an item and
it's not there
so
when i call
word starting by letter with this
letter
if it's empty it's going to create a new
list for me
and return that and then i can just
append to it immediately
so this is uh the beauty of default dict
it basically we'll call this what's
called factory sorry in my example list
when it looks up a key that isn't there
and similarly this is an example from
the official docs here we create a
default dictionary where the factory is
int so if we try and look up something
from the dictionary or from the default
dictionary and it is not there so that
key isn't in it it's gonna
add
an integer which will start off as zero
so now from mississippi i can say for
letter in
in mississippi
look up that letter and add one so the
reason you can just look up that letter
and add one immediately you know it's
not going to cause an error when it's
empty it's just going to start it off at
zero so this is another way of
getting back to the letter counts
cool how we doing okay great
name tuple uh they're
they're great they here i've got a
student
so this is our student data from earlier
but here i might be making a a tuple to
represent a student simon ward jones 30
he is on vacation and he's got some
quality test scores
but you don't know what they are and
it's quite hard to read if you're
reading it because you just have to rely
on the person
knowing which one's which so maybe i'm
writing a simple function to display
that student and i want to print student
student zero so i'm going to look up
their name is
student one years old but it's quite
like hard you have to you have to check
which
which position that specific thing you
want to look up is in
so i can call that and it will print
print my information about the student
but instead let's create a named tuple
called student so the first when this is
the name tuple function from
collections you give the name of the uh
the name tube also this is going to be a
student
and you can either both of these are the
same you can either give a string with
space separated names for each of the
the items in your name tuple or you can
give a list so here i'm specifying that
i want the first thing represents a name
the second is an age and it's just a
little bit more readable than a tuple
otherwise it's very similar to a tuple
so now i can create
a student in a much more readable way
it's still it's still a tuple in that
you can still look up the second item
and get that i am on vacation
but you can now use the on ma vacation
attribute as well so it's just it just
makes your code a little bit easier now
if i just rewrite that same function
when i'm
putting the name and the age and the
test scores into my string i can
reference the dot name and it's going to
make it a bit easier to read easier to
edit
but still
similar to a tuple
do you have a question
sure
uh so
i think one one thing that's quite nice
about a name tuple is you could use it
as a key
in
in another dictionary whereas you
couldn't do that with a dictionary
there's one example i think name tuples
are they're immutable so you can't you
can't change them once you've made them
and that comes with some some benefits
as well
i think that they'll be the key ones
that jump to mind
uh but so i can run that function again
and it comes with this underscore
replace method
and look a tuple is immutable so you
can't change something
in the tuple once you've made it but
this replace will return a new instance
a new tuple but with that thing changed
out so here i can change the age to 31
it's going to create a new tuple called
older simon and you can see
with the age one when you're on so
that's the sort of convenience
you look up the fields so the names of
those specific
items in the tuple
but we can also do the same thing with
uh
named tuple from
typing so it's just another way to
create exactly the same uh data
structure but just with a slightly
different syntax uh using type hinting
so this is from the typing library you
can import name tuple and i thought i'd
just show you here because it's it's
creating exactly the same thing but
you're specifying the types as well so
now we've got name age on vacation and
test
scores but with some additional
information that it's going to be a
string and a bool
and
a list of integers for the test scores
so again i can create the same thing
and uh still it's a tuple and i can pick
out the first
sorry
i don't know why i've shown you that i
know i know why so earlier we now gonna
look at this method called make
so imagine i did have a list of
dictionaries so here's my fake data from
earlier we had our three students
with these properties and dictionaries
i can have a look at the first one we
can loop through and use the underscore
make method on our name tuple passing it
uh
a list or an iterable of the values so
for each of our student in student data
so i can there i'm making some name
tuples so i'm just converting
dictionaries into name tuples there if
you
have to back to your question why would
you make some tuples instead of a
dictionary these you could
use those keys somewhere else if you
wanted to later
so uh challenge number three remembering
we've gone through name tuples which are
great for
giving your
points names we've gone through
collections
with uh
sorry collections is the whole set we've
gone through double ended queues
counter great for counting
and
one more but i can't remember
so the challenge is to create a name
tuple
called point and it's to it should have
an x and a y
and it represents a point on a grid
so that's that's what we got to create
and then ideally create a list with 100
points
with x values in one two and three and y
values in one two and three so just some
points on a very small grid make a
hundred of those
uh random points and then find the most
common point
now that we've we've done the simulation
we've picked loads of 100 random points
how might you find the most common point
in this simulation
also you might need to import random and
use the random dot random between one
and three because that's not what we're
trying to learn here
so i'll give you i'll give you one
minute to have a go at this
okay 30 more seconds then i'll we'll go
through how you might do this
um
okay i'm seeing a few people who look
like they've done so let's let's go
through this one and and see how we can
use some of what we learned above so
firstly i'm just going to import random
from random
as a bit of a tip so this is one way you
could have created a point you give the
name of the name tuple so point using a
capital letter and then x and y you
could have done a list with strings x
and y in it or you can use the named
tuple class from typing and again do x
and y so now we have this nice name
tuple
representing a point
i can use that like so to generate 100
random
points
on my grid of one to three
uh and then i'm going to call i'm going
to create a counter using points
and so it's going to go through and
count each occurrence of each point and
then i can call most common and get just
the first most common element and that's
going to be a list with however many so
it's going to have one item in it the
most common
so i get that out of the list and it's a
it's a tuple with two things
uh the
the point itself and the count so here
let's let's go ahead and show you this
step by step
in here
so
if i just run this
points they're all my points
and now we can do
counter points in fact let's break it up
a little
bit uh
like so
now we can look at the counter
and that will look like this so it's got
the counts for each of the random points
that we made
and then we can call most common
on on this counter dot most common let's
get the most common point and you can
see it's this point and that's the count
and then all i did there was
take that out and then i can
i can print it
so that's how you might do that using
counter and i think it's quite intuitive
to a person reading this code okay so
we're counting the points and then we're
getting the most common one out of it
and i'm sure you could write a different
code to do the same thing but it's very
readable using uh
counter
does anyone have any questions about any
of those or should i move on to it tools
questions
uh only if it's hashable so that's the
kind of rule so it can tell that it's
counting the same thing
cool so let's go on to ester tools which
i think is the most fun fun one we're
going to go through
and the most useful i think potentially
in at least in in the work i do in data
science
so just to remind you we've got our
students and we're going to carry on
using them just so i don't have to keep
creating new pretend concepts
as a quick aside it's
we can think about what is an iterable
and what is an iterator
and how does a for loop really work so
this is a slight aside and and i'll jump
back to it uh tools and the
functionality that offers but i think
it's it's good to sometimes think about
conceptually what are these things so
an iterator is an object that implements
the iterator protocol
and that means it implements these two
special dunder methods or double
underscore methods ita and next
it returns the iterator object itself
and next returns
uh the next element so in terms of when
you're looping
an iterator you can think you start at
the beginning it's going to give you the
first thing then you call the method
next to move on to the next thing and
that's going to enable us to loop
through it and i'll give an example of
why that's useful
and an iterable it just implements
the issue method that returns an
iterable
so don't worry you're still a little bit
lost i will give an example
now
we have student data which is a list
and it is an iterable
and we can tell it's an iterable because
it has
an ita method
and we can iterate over it using the
normal for syntax so we can say for item
in student data print item so you can
see i've looped through and i've printed
our three student dictionaries out so
hopefully that's that's familiar that's
that's our for loop
but we can also call the item method
directly on our list
and it returns a list iterator so this
is the double underscore and you can
achieve exactly the same thing
as calling the double underscore method
by calling ita the built-in method
directly on that list and that's also
going to return a list iterator
and this list iterator
uh is gonna
so let's create it so now i've called it
student data iterator
and it has the special method next
and to get the next element we can
either call double underscore next the
the special method
or you can use the built-in next
so we call that on our iterator
it returns the next thing in the list so
we'll write at the beginning or in the
list iterators that it's going to return
john we call it again it will return
jane
and isaac
and if we run it one more time
it's going to raise an error and say
look i'm out of items now
so that's under the hood that's what's
happening so we can this is a summary
your pseudo code of what's happening in
a for loop so the first thing the for
loop syntax will do is it will call ita
on the thing you're looping over and now
we've got an iterator and we know that
this must have the special
next method so a for loop essentially
says while true
try to get the next item
from our iterator
this bit is effectively the block of
your for loop
and then at the end it's going to accept
finally when when it errors let's just
break and return so this is
basically a pseudo implementation of
what our for loop's doing but it's nice
to think what what's an iterator it's
it's something that you can call next on
so now let's have some fun
with its tools
so again i'm going to try and ask you to
think what would happen
or what does this represent before i run
the example so here i've got three lists
three iterables and it's a tools.chain
it's going to chain them together
so it might not surprise you if i go
through for city in numbers that's a
quite a bad name
let's change that
uh for a number in chain print number so
it's going to chain them all together
into one long iterable
why might you want to do this i'm just
kind of
adding this
on the fly so
you could do this
you could say add
and maybe i'll cover this more again but
this is going to build a new list it's
going to go and make that place in
memory and it's going to build that list
whereas when we did it this way using
either tools chain it's not creating any
new list in memory it's just create it's
going to go through the first one go and
find the second one in memory and then
go through that and then go and find the
third one and uh go through that so it's
much more efficient to use a chain than
to build a new list like that so you
could have done that and said all
numbers you know we could have called
this
all numbers
if i can type
and then we could have looped through
that instead
but we won't we'll just use the chain
because it's it's easier to
read and understand i think
again if yeah chain from iterable is
very similar it's just when you have
them already in in another it's also
here we've got a list and in that we
have lists so
you'll see the difference between
chain and chain from iterable
it's just that if we have
a list of lists then you might want to
use chain permissible but it's going to
do the same thing it's going to go
through each of the sub items
of each of the sub items
so count
is an iterator representing a count and
you give it an initial value so
uh
here we are starting with three
so for and
someone have got yeah
uh
good question i think it probably does
my guess would be it does i've never
tried an infinite chain we could we
could try that
in a second i guess
we'll come back to that i think i think
what i could show you an example of that
in a minute if we've got if we've got
time
uh it's always risky trying to do
something on the fly but we can use the
cycle which i'm going to show you in a
second
and then and then come back to it so
let's have a look at that
so this count yeah it starts with a
count and each time you call it it's
going to give you the next in the count
so for n in it's a tools count start at
one step is one we're going to print
what the value of n is and i'm actually
just gonna say if if we get to five i
hope we get a five then let's break out
and stop
so there i'm printing numbers one to
five
just to show you another exact same way
of doing the same thing
we could say n equals one so let's just
start at one while n is less than six
print it
if n equals to five actually you don't
even need this d
uh
n plus equals one so it's just a
different
a different way of of creating a count
series of numbers
uh combinations is probably the the one
i use the most day to day so if we've
got numbers one to four and you want to
create all the combinations of two out
of that uh of that number you can call
combinations so here it's going to
return a list of tuples with one two one
and three one and four and all the
combinations
and then you've got combinations with
replacement which is the same thing but
replacing so you can get one and one
whereas in combinations it's only with a
different with a different item
cycle is quite quite a fun one uh it
basically when you get to the end of
whatever your issue rater is it will
just go back and start at the beginning
so it is an infinite
iterator
and so we could try it out with chain if
we wanted to so here i've got a function
let's say i'm simulating some game
uh player move it's gonna take a player
and if
a random number is equal between one and
four is about one uh
that player won the game so we'll return
true uh else just say that the player
moved so that's my simulation function
and now i'm going to do the simulation
so i'm going to say for player in ital's
cycle a and b if the player move returns
true i have they won
then we'll break out the loop
so if we run that once you can see
it didn't take that long but if we run
this it's randomly playing a move but
it's going to cycle through our players
and that could be really useful in those
kind of contexts
uh group by
i think it's best seen
as an example so if we take mississippi
it returns
a iterable with returns for two pools
the first item being
one of the
members of this
uh iterable and the other is all of the
occurrences of that
item so if i make it a bit easier if we
say for key group and then i can just
convert this group into
a list so we can see it so you can see
in the first loop around it's the m and
you get just one because there's only
one m
same with the i but with the s it finds
the next so it groups these two into a
run so it's got ss
yeah so that's where you get the ss so
it's good for kind of grouping runs of
items in an iterable
yeah
yes
i think
i slice is another really useful
one so here if you have an iterable you
can specify a starting point an ending
point and a step size
uh
i guess this one i i do go into again
why it's
why it's better or potentially more
useful than another way of doing it so
here i'm creating a really long list
with a million things and i've just
written a function that's going to tell
us how big it is in memory so if i show
you it's a 7.6 megabyte list
and
if i use this syntax which is one way of
slicing it and it will create a new list
and i'm going to start at the beginning
don't stop until the end and step every
two
and it's half as big so it's not
surprising because i've picked out half
the items of the list half of the
million
however if we look at the same thing
with ital's slice and look at the memory
of that it's 72 bytes so it's completely
tiny because it it's
it's not going to when when we loop
through it
it would it would just look up the items
as as you go from the existing iterable
so again it can be a bit more memory
efficient
permutations
really similar to combinations
but order's important so now you'll have
just
the
different permutations of the numbers
but with r it tells you how how many
you want so i want all the sets of two
in all the unique permutations so i
could say i want
three
and give me all the sets of three from
my iterable in all the different
permutations
uh product
if you've got two iterables and you want
to find the product of the two so you
have one and four one and five
so that's pairing each each element in
each of the iterables with all of the
other
elements in the other iterables
and you can also use this repeat
argument if
if you just want to
find the product of the list with itself
and then the last method i'll go through
in is the tools there are there are a
few more but these are the sort of ones
i find most useful day to day
is
zip longest so zip is a standard
built in and if we zipped one and two
and a b and c they purposely made them
different lengths
uh we get it kind of zips them together
so it's putting the first item of the
first one with the first item of the
second list and so on but because
there's no third item we've just lost
uh the c
so with itators at longest
it will pair them all and where it can't
find something it will just put a nun in
so that can be quite useful
i also found when i was writing this
talk i found out that you can call
strict equals true mode
on the normal zip function and that's
just going to error if they're not the
same length which is also
could be handy if you didn't if you were
expecting them to be the same length and
you want them to
error
so that was it tools
and a challenge here
is to
find how many times does each number
appear in the multiples of three
less than a thousand
so three
six nine twelve the 12 has a one and a
two in it how can you find uh
the
counts of these and because we're
running a tiny bit short on time and i
want to go through funk tools and have a
little bit of time for questions
i'll just show you the answer this one
so this is how you might do it
what have i got
so i've got my three times table
and
i've got a range of a thousand and i'm
going to step through in the three times
table so starting at three
uh
none
no end and taking steps of three so this
is going to be all the numbers all the
three times table i'm going to convert
them into strings
so i have now a generator because i've
not done square brackets just to show
you that if you're really caring about
your
uh you don't want to use any memory here
you want it in a generator form
and then i'm going to do chain from
iterable so you can think of the
this as one interval and inside it has
little strings so we can call chain from
iterable and then put that in a counter
so i'm kind of putting everything
together as a bit of a complex example
here but we're going to get to the point
where we've got for each of the
different numbers how many times they're
counted so we can see there's this kind
of nice three-ish pattern going on in
the three times table which makes sense
and
the what was the challenge yeah to find
out how many each square so we've done
the challenge and you can go and sort of
go back through that and see see how
we've used kind of the slice which is
really memory efficient and we've done
the chain from each of the separate
strings to chain them into one so you
can think it's going through the one
sorry the three and then the six
and then the nine and then the one of
the twelve and then the two of the
twelve and so we're going to step
through in all of the the numbers like
that
cool so that's it's tools does anyone
have any questions before we go on to
the last the last topic
and i'm throwing quite a lot of examples
but i thought it's good to give you a
flavor of what you can do with the
libraries or the modules sorry
so let's import fung tools the last one
and we're going to talk first about the
last recent
cache and
as of python 3.9 the cache
decorators so let's first talk about
this function it's called factorial so
we want to find the factorial of say 5
is 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 times 1.
so one way you could implement that is
you say start with the number
and multiply it by the output of the
previous factorial
if n is if n else zero so basically if n
is not zero and if n is zero return a
one
and i'm going to do the same function
again
i'm going to call it fast factorial but
i'm going to apply func tools lru cache
with no maximum size
and i'll explain a bit more about what
this is doing as as funk tools a
decorator
is a function that acts on another
function this is the function it's
acting on it's going to take this one
and make a new function it's going to
give it the same name fast factorial but
it's going to
add a cache as well so when it calls
and tries to find the uh factorial of
tetin it's going to check first in a
little cache it keeps and say do i know
what the uh
do i know what the first factorial of or
the factorial of 10 is if so return it
else let's start calculating so that's
that's the idea of a cache and this is
one implemented for you in the standard
library so we can time
how long it takes to run the factorial
uh for 200 it takes 36
microseconds and then we can do fast
factorial
and it takes
60 nanoseconds so it's like
thousands of times
faster and that's because
you can think of it has to it's it's
calculating the low number of factorials
a lot because it's very recursive so
having a recursive function with an lru
cache can have massive improvements on
how fast the function can run
the
the max size is just how big you want
your cache to be by default
you often just
i often just want to have no maximum
size to just go ahead and use loads of
memory
uh and
as a python 3.9 you can just use dot
cache to do that so you don't need to
specify
max size equals none
cool so another example i wanted to go
through was total ordering
so we're going back to the student
example but now we're going to do a
class implementation so this is how
you'd create a class
basic
class version of what we had
say
with an init method where we're going to
take in the name and age some test
scores and on vacation
and save those as
variables or attributes on the class
we've got a wrapper to make it look nice
when we print it
in a jupiter notebook and we've also got
this property
where we're going to return the mean
test score from so we're just summing
the test scores and dividing by the
length so that might be a property you
want to know about your students
so now we can make
using the data from earlier we're just
going to make two students
so we've got one called john smith with
the same data as earlier and one isaac
newton
and uh
you can see it's using the wrapper that
we defined here as normal
but if we wanted to do this if you want
to compare john and newton out the box
with what we've written so far python's
going to error and say that it doesn't
know how to compare these two
objects which is fine but we can
implement we can tell python with the
special methods here
how to compare
two instances of this class
so
you implement this special less than
dunder method less than or equal to
greater than greater than or equal to
and equal
and
so if we were comparing a student with
another student what i actually wanted
to do is check whether the mean test
scores
of the two students are
ones bigger than the other so say if i
want to compare these two objects and i
actually what i really want to do is
just compare their test score so if
newton is bigger using the term bigger
might be slightly strange but it means
that they've got a higher test score so
that's that's how you would implement
this in
a normal setting and now i can go ahead
and compare john is not greater than
isaac newton
which isn't surprising
and what's happening under the hood when
you run
a comparison of these two custom
instances is it's calling the greater
than or equal to method so john greater
than or equal to newton and it's going
to go and find my implementation and
compare their mean test scores
but what total ordering is from funk
tools library
it's a class decorator
which means we only need to implement
two of the comparisons
and it makes sense that you only need
two
because
you can infer all the others from two
like if you're
not less than and you're not equal to it
means you're greater than and and so
what python does is it goes and
implements in the background all of the
other
uh
ones that you're missing
so by adding total ordering now i could
only do two of them
and you can actually see
if you call double question mark in
jupiter you get some information about
that method and you can see that it it
calls less than
and then it says if not for operation
result and then they're not equal
then it must be greater than so it's
given us this for free and that's this
uh total ordering decorator from fung
tools
so again a slightly more advanced
concept of you're implementing these
instance comparisons you only need to do
two and then let total ordering do all
the others
okay cool and i think when
yeah we're nearly at the end the other
one i think is quite useful is
partial so imagine if we have this
method called is pass
and it's taking a student
and it's taking a pass mark and then it
says they have passed if their mean test
score is bigger than the pass mark
and then we're going to print that
test score
whether it's above or below the pass
mark
so and then it's going to return whether
they passed so let's try that has john
passed john smith has test score below
60 and false he hasn't passed
unlucky
and then we can do the same thing with
newton he has a test score above 60.
good news he's passed
and now imagine you want to
write a function called is topsat which
is very similar
and it's going to take a student and
just return whether
they've passed with a 30 with a 30 test
mark
so you could implement this like this
where it defers to the is path method
and fixes the second argument is 30.
and
uh now i can call that is top set so yes
newton is top set his
his mark is above 30.
but there's another way you can do this
you can actually create the function on
the fly so you don't need to have the
function definition
which means that you can sort of
programmatically do this
using other lists and objects but let's
say we this is the function
and i want to fix the pass mark at 80
and this partial
returns a new function called is top set
so here i've done the same thing i've
said fix the pass mark argument to this
function as 80 and give me a new
function so now i've got is top set
it's a different way of implementing his
top set
and i can again i can do that
call that
say isaac newton does a test group of
80.
so let's do a different example
we're going to import median from
statistics
and i can call the min on a list of
tuples and you might know that it's it
looks at the first item in the tuples
when comparing
these to find the minimum so one is the
minimum of five and two and one
however if you do you can also pass key
to the min and
you specify how to look up in each of my
items what to compare against
so here i take the items and look at the
the second thing in in
index on zero so it's going to compare
based on the two the one and the three
so if i run that it's going to pull out
this as the minimum item because it's
comparing now the second things in each
of the little tuples
so now let's let's let's use this and
create a partial
of the min function but let's fix
the key
to be to look up the student's median
test score
so now i'm taking the min function this
partial is going to return us a new
function i'm calling it min student
because i'm fixing the key as this
lambda so it's going to look up in each
of the items
the test the median test scores so now
that i've got this min students function
i could use that on a selection of
students to find
our worst performing media and student
so that's a way you could for instance
use a
partial i was just i was coming up with
a random example so the last exercise to
have a go
is to create a function called student
pairs
to find all uh combination of two
students actually as we've only got a
few minutes left i will show you the
answer this one as well
so here
what have i done i've used
yeah this is slightly abstract maybe you
wouldn't do it this way if you really
wanted to do it but
to explain what it's doing is taking the
combinations function from its tools
and pinning r
which is the number of combinations you
want to find as two so now this is a
function student pairs that's going to
return
the combinations but fixed at just two
items so then i can call that on my
students
to find all the combinations of students
there's not very many here but you can
see how i found john
jane john isaac and jane
and
isaac
cool so that that was a the all i wanted
to go through in these libraries yeah
sure
with my pie and partials oh i've no i've
not used
partial since i've
used my pie so
i don't i don't have not seen that one
i guess
any other questions and i can show you
just one quick example that i put in the
code
so i've written some code here hopefully
you can see
and i'll show you what it does first
it's pretty exciting
so we can run in the script by golden
code
tic-tac-toe
and it's a it's a implementation of
tic-tac-toe and it says you can under a
move re-do a move quit save and quit
load a saved game and select the number
of players so i'm going to select one
player
and you can see we've got my tic-tac-toe
board
and i can specify a move
so i've gone in the top left and that's
the computer's go
and i can undo some moves
so undo that computer move i didn't like
that one let's have a different one
uh
then i can go in the middle
let the computer go oh
i'm gonna go for the win and have one uh
that that's the game but what i wanted
to show you is just a few of the things
we've gone through
very briefly
so at the top of the file
i'm going to specify a data directory
and i use this in quite a lot of scripts
so i'm saying from the current location
of the file let's create a path find the
parent
and then add on a data folder so this is
going to save
this is a place where i'm going to save
games so that's a thing you might use i
use it if i'm saving features in a model
or you know i'm looking up a
configuration file or i've got a
training folder test folder you can
build them using path live like this
and now i've got a named tuple this is
going to represent my moves during the
game and a move has a player and where
they've gone
so just a number from one to nine i've
already so that's an integer and that's
a player so that's how i'm using my name
tuple
uh
so i just wanted to go down to
here this is a slightly contrived
example i admit that we're going to try
and calculate the winner of tic-tac-toe
after every single move
and i've actually implemented some
separate sub functions called rows
columns and diagonals and they return
the rows of my board and then the
columns
and the two diagonals
so here when i want to check who's won
i want to loop through all of these
different
iterables
and so this group is going to be a
three long it's going to either and it's
going to be either a row a column or a
diagonal as we loop through
and then i'm going to use a counter
because we've used the counter and i'm
going to count the things in this group
of three and it's either x's for player
x it's either z o's for player o or none
because there's no one in there so then
i can just check
okay let's look up the counter
for the x symbol
and if that's equal to three then x is
one because it's got three in a row and
do the same for o and we know if there's
no x's it's not going to fail because
counter just returns a zero when we try
and look up the thing that we've got so
this is quite a lot of
a contrived example but i think it shows
you how you can chain three things
together in a in a slightly real world
setting
that's what i wanted to show you uh and
thank thanks very much for listening
i'll take any questions if you've got
any
[Applause]